I end up getting sentenced 26
years um it's a lot of years I would
like to tell you that they they when
they gave me the time you know that I I
was stoic and I I stood there and I I
took it in you know but but the truth is
I cried like a baby like a small child
like you've never seen anyone cry like
this in your life I was just how did I
get 26 how what did I do to get 26 years
like murderers rapists I've met guys
that kidnapped guys that got
156 so yeah hey I were you
scared I mean you know does a pope wear
a funny hat like of course I was SC
terrified yeah I mean you know but I
kept telling myself ah they're going to
reduce the sentent they'll reduce it
they'll reduce it they'll reduce it like
okay okay okay it's going to be okay
it's going to be okay um you know but it
wasn't okay I I I got I got moved to
Coleman the
Coleman complex in Coleman Florida the
federal correctional Coleman complex in
Coleman Florida which is the largest
complex in the nation uh Federal complex
in the nation there's a there's a at
that time there was a a camp which was a
female Camp there was a medium security
a low security prison for men a medium
security prison and two
penitentiaries and so I get moved to the
medium I'm moved to the medium not
because like that's where like real
criminals go right like I'm I'm a soft
white boy like I'm no danger to anybody
like I I hurt I hurt someone's feelings
once but other than that I'm I'm I'm not
a pro I'm not going to be a problem but
if you have more than 20 years to serve
you have to go to a medium so even
though my sec security level said this
guy should be in a camp mhm I had 20
years so if you have you can't go to a
camp till you have less than 10 so as
soon as I given 26 years and and you
know 26 years they they knock off three
but you still have three years to get
below 20 so they go to the medium so I
go to the medium and their guy is
getting stabbed the very first day
people are being
stabbed I get locked into you go to my
cell meet my C they scream lock down
somebody got stabbed in the wreck yard I
remember I my C which I met 20 minutes
earlier I was like what's you know he's
like hey we got to get in the cell I was
like what's going on he somebody got
stabbed in the yard and I go somebody
just got killed and he goes nah they
just stabbed him up a little bit and I
thought you're in a place where they say
stabbed them up a little bit like you're
not prepared for this bro you got to get
out of here yeah so anyway I go to the
medium I'm there like what was the first
day and night when remember I already
had been locked up in the county and
they their County jails where they call
them us they US Marshall they're
holdovers but they're really County
jails they just keep you with the with
the um Federal guys so I'm not mixed in
with like hobos and you know people like
that like I'm I'm mixed in with the
federal people so already felt like a
like a prison yeah it's it's it's a
prison I mean it's it's jail but it's a
prison and andless you've been locked up
you don't really know the difference so
it's it's a jail jails suck jails are
much worse the whole time I was locked
up in these in the jails waiting to be
sentenced guys were like I just want to
get sentence and go go to prison bro I
just and I was like why does everybody
keep saying that like prison's worse
than this like I saw shank Shaw Shank
it's horrible and they're like bro
prison listen prison I can walk the
wreck yard I could go to the movie room
watch movies I'll listen within right
after count for this four o' count they
count everybody at four so they are like
right after count I'm going to go to
commissary somebody's going to buy me an
ice cream I'm going to be eating an ice
cream walking on the wreck yard the
first day like and I'm you know it's
been months and months and months and
I've been locked up in this County jail
and I'm thinking I want to go to prison
like that sounds nice I'd love I'd like
an ice cream yeah but there was a
stabbing in the first day well you know
everybody kept telling me I was going to
go to a camp you're going to go to a
camp you're going to go to a low I see
you know and and honestly I I was very
quickly I was walking on the wreck yard
I was you know so I was at the medium I
got
there you know it's it's a real prison
with the doors bam and they can open the
little tray thing and feed you out of
the tray and there's a a stainless steel
toilet and sink and you know they have
that in the county too but you know it's
it's exactly what you think of prison as
being but it feels like a fundamentally
different experience when it's 26 years
and the door locks and yeah so I yeah I
have a
c and but I'm also they sent me to a
prison where guys have tons of guys have
30 40 50 years you know life sentences
there's there's gangsters there there's
uh there's murderers there's serial
killers there's you know really bad guys
uh there's you know there's guys that
are you know trying to take advantage
of guys right you like sexually yeah um
but by the time I got there I'd heard
all the you know how you can get
yourself in trouble you know how you can
like don't go in somebody else's cell
you don't know the guy you're not 100%
sure do not go in his cell don't even go
near his cell don't go into places where
people can close a door behind you or
they can trap you in an area don't
there's all these things that I've been
told not to do again for sexual reasons
right because I'm I'm a
small guy in prison yeah you know track
the away dude yeah it's a problem it's a
problem
this yeah it's it's bad it's all bad
well it's good in the outside world but
not bad in the pron you know yeah my
fear was there make me shave my head to
make sure that the mop wig fits
correctly but there's certain things
that I always hate to say this but Ian
and it do this is a simplest way to say
it is that if you get stabbed in prison
you had it Comon you did something like
they're not running around just stabbing
people you did something you and and the
things that get you hurt is you argue
over the TV what channel you want to
watch you got 50 80 guys watching One TV
don't argue about it like it's no just
not worth it um borrowing things that
and not returning them that's a problem
running up debts that's a big problem
you know
gambling gossiping you know those are
the problem those things get you hurt
not being polite be respectful I'm super
respectful
that